Oh
the blunt answer is no there's maybe 15
to 20 companies that have started doing
this they've done it for a year or two
and a few cases has been five or six so
the database is much too small that you
could do the type of analysis that a
financial economist would do to be able
to link integrated reporting to superior
shareholder return if you talk to people
in the companies and you say what do you
think the benefits are that you've
received from doing integrated reporting
they will say two certainly improved
internal coordination it has certainly
made sustainability more real in terms
of it's a core part of the strategy it's
embedded in operations they would say it
has improved the understanding that the
stakeholder community has of the company
and the relationship between financial
and non-financial performance but to be
fair they would say that the shareholder
community is still struggling to
understand this other kind of
information my response to that would be
it's a necessary educational process
that companies need to go through with
their shareholders so at this point in
time the benefits that companies would
explain are primarily internal but i do
believe over time and clearly these
companies believe over time that this
will lead to a superior long-term
performance the issue of timeframe is
important because integrated reporting
title of my book is one report
integrated reporting for a sustainable
strategy it's really about the long-term
so companies have to take the long-term
shareholders have to take the long term
investors who are short-term oriented
hedge funds technical trading programs a
lot of hedge funds probably aren't going
to be interested that's not the
shareholder community that companies
that are producing an integrated report
are trying to appeal to personally I
think that's part of the problem with
our capital markets today I think it's
one of the major reasons that we had the
recent financial crisis was this short
term shareholder only oriented mentality
integrated reporting as a way of taking
a broader stakeholder view of rethinking
the role of corporations in society
and stretching out the time frames under
which both companies and investors make
their decisions